et nous fournissons des services vitaux aux
personnes sans abri et qui
dorment dans la rue en fournissant tout, de
l'accès à un médecin à un dentiste se douche
une coupe de cheveux
[Musique]
et essentiellement il s'agit de fournir aux
gens un moyen de se sortir
de l'itinérance grâce à
un
soutien initial qui  nous leur fournissons
nous faisons ce que nous pouvons pour aider les sans-
abri nous essayons de faire pression sur le
gouvernement pour qu'il modifie ses politiques afin d'
empêcher les sans-abri de venir dans nos
rues en premier lieu mais nous
avons tous un rôle à jouer je pense que nous  peut mettre fin au
sommeil agité nous l'avons fait dans le passé nous
pouvons le refaire
pour le crédit universel, les
systèmes de congé ont pris fin et et il y a
maintenant la fin des expulsions que
vous